thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftus and i'm denise valdez breaking
news in the west valley tonight metro
police on the scene of a homicide near
charleston and town center detectives
are searching for the suspect who police
say shot and killed one person and
injured another christian costar is live
near that scene he's got an update
brian and denise good evening metro
police just finished giving us those
details and according to preliminary
information they say this shooting was
targeted i'll take a look here at the
scene now this is a shopping center off
of charleston and south town center
driving as you can see there's heavy
police presence at this hour now police
telling us that they were notified
around 7 50 this evening about a
shooting when they arrived they found
two people were shot one passed away
that victim they say was a 40 year old
man the second victim was a 48 year old
woman she has been taken to umc where
she remains critical tonight police also
telling us that this was a customer
employee situation they believe the
suspect followed the victim inside a
business here and fired multiple shots
before fleeing officers telling us other
employees and customers were present
inside the business but were uninjured
as for the suspect will they tell us the
suspect fled on foot he is or that
person is described as a black male
adult thin built dark clothing dark
sweatshirt shorts and he was wearing a
black baseball hat now police are asking
for the public's help as they continue
to talk to several witnesses here on
scene but again two people shot tonight
one dead and another critical in the
hospital of course we will continue to
gather more information and have all
that information available for you on
our website on eight newsnow dot com
christian casa is live local now